so the first thing you want to know is
that one degree is equivalent to 16
minutes so that's what this little mark
here represents and then one minute is
equivalent to 60 seconds and that's what
these two marks here represent seconds
so you can think of a degree kind of
like an hour there's 60 minutes in an
hour and then there's 60 seconds in a
minute
so there's 3,600 seconds in one hour and
again remember just think about hours as
like degrees so in this example we're
going to convert from 4 degrees 50
minutes 12 seconds to just degrees okay
so here's what we're gonna do let's take
the 50 minutes first and you can see
that for every 1 degree there are 60
minutes anything divided by 1 is itself
so I'm putting 50 over 1 and what you
can see happens here is that the minutes
units they cancel each other out see a
numerator and denominator and we're left
with the degree units which is what we
want so if we go ahead and multiply
across here we get this is 50 60th of a
degree and let's go ahead and convert
that into a decimal form here so let's
just see 50/60 comes out to 0.8 3 3 3
repeating right so this is 0.8 3 3 3 now
if we look at the seconds to 12 seconds
let's go down here we know that there
are let's see there are 4 every 60
seconds there is 1 minute right and we
also know that for every 60 minutes
there are one degree okay and the way
we've set this up is so that the units
we don't want see the seconds they
cancel numerator and denominator and
same thing with the minutes those units
cancel we don't want those so they
cancel a numerator denominator and we're
left with degrees which is the unit that
we do want so you can see if we multiply
across you multiply all the numerators
we get 12 all the denominators we get
3600 and if we divide those let's see
what we get in decimal form so we get 12
divided by 3600 which comes out to Oh
point zero zero three three three
repeating so zero zero three three like
salt so if we add this up we've got the
four degrees okay point zero zero zero
zero
and we've got the minutes it was
converted degrees the second converted
degree so if we add straight down you
can see this is going to be four point
eight three six six and so on degrees so
that's it so that's all you have to do
is think about these conversion factors
sixty minutes for every one degree 60
seconds for every one minute and then
set it up so that the units you don't
want cancel and you can convert
everything into just degrees so I want
to thank my patreon for supporting the
making of this video if you're
interested in supporting me making more
videos like this for you check out my
patreon page consider making a donation
of a $1 or $3 whatever is comfortable
for you to help the making of these
videos and subscribe to the channel
check out more math videos on Mario's
math tutor and YouTube channel and I'll
see you in the future videos I'll talk
to you soon